[Musique]
c'est une décision qui divise n'est que
romain lopez maire de moissac a décidé
de prendre la suppression totale des
allocations d'une famille d'un
délinquant c'était lui et rennes a
estimé juste de punir les parents du
jeune homme de 14 ans qu'ils considèrent
comme responsable de son éducation j'ai
décidé de signaler à ses parents
totalement irresponsable des
missionnaires qui ne bénéficieraient
plus de la solidarité municipale leur
enfant est poursuivi pour plusieurs
faits mineurs dégradation de bien public
outrage à agents et autres faits
similaires nous avons un jeune de la
commune qui s'est permis de dégrader
avec un de ses couverts des fenêtres du
lycée l'école et qu' il y a quelques
jours s'est permis de cracher sur les
voitures la police municipale pour ma
lopez met donc en garde tous ceux qui
voudraient enfin de les règles dans sa
ville dans notre ville il ya des règles
de vie à respecter ceux qui ne la
respectent pas c'est très faire pour moi
et qu'ils entendent bien ce message une
bénéficieront plus de la solidarité
municipale alors suppression des
allocations pour une famille de
délinquants comprenez vous la décision
du maire
et il est avec nous le maire de moissac
romain lopez merci d'être avec nous
merci ça serait bien ça va ça bon alors
vous êtes content de votre décision
m content j'ai tout simplement à
appliquer la loi à savoir que mr a des
pouvoirs de police qui lui sont octroyés
par la loi et les messages ministry mois
eut pour assurer l'autorité la
tranquillité publique la salubrité
l'ordre public donc j'utilise tous les
arsenaux juridiques de position de quoi
le jeune homme est il coupable le jeune
homme en l'occurrence a commis plusieurs
actes d'incivilité comme il ajouté des
cailloux sur les fenêtres d'un lycée
agricole pour cela il ya une dépôt de
plainte c'est pour ça que j'ai pas pu
d'ailleurs déclenché de la procédure de
rappel à l'ordre qui peut être déclenché
que lorsqu'il n'y a pas de procédure
judiciaire c'est pour justement éviter
l'enclenchement d'une procédure
judiciaire en l'occurrence gelé j'ai
souhaité le convoquer pour un rappel à
l'ordre avec l'aval du procureur de la
république lorsqu'il a craché sur la
voiture de la police municipale
et lorsque la police est allée à sa
rencontre il a dit écoutez moi je m'en
fous je paye pas donc face
il a 14 ans d'accord donc face à ce
sentiment d'impunité on a souhaité le
rappeler à l'ordre avec ses parents il a
reçu pour seulement comme une question
gérer convoquer les parents oui tout à
fait alors mineure et est convoqué
automatiquement mais les parents et le
jour de cette convocation on attendait
désespérément mais le chef de la police
municipale et la gendarmerie et ils ne
sont jamais venus donc lorsque la police
est allée les chercher leur ont dit que
ça ne les intéressait pas qu'ils avaient
d'autres choses à faire par conséquent
je ne pouvais pas par rapport aux
rappels à l'ordre qui fait partie du
pouvoir de police du maire avoir ma
parole
totalement 1 qui partait en l'air
d'accord et j'ai souhaité donner quoi
les parents les parents eux m'ont dit
que ça ne les intéressait pas devenir et
le jeune adolescent non plus d'accord et
moi je ne sais pas alors vous avez pris
quoi comme mesure alors suite à cela
bien sûr on l'a on en a informé le
procureur la république et j'ai écrit un
courrier que j'expliquais donc dans
cette vidéo en disant à cette famille
que lorsqu elle souhaiterait bénéficier
à l'avenir des social municipal
facultative liés au ccs elle ne le
pourrait pas tant qu'elle ne reviendrait
pas sur sa décision d'accord alors
aujourd'hui donc vous avez coupé
c'est ça
ils ne seront plus éligibles si jamais
ils font une demande auprès du ce et 16
les aides secours puisque nous dans
l'autre pour l'instant mon instinct
énormément même effectivement si le
demande ils ne rentreront plus dans les
critères qui seront dit il
visiblement ils ont réagit donc ça
prouve que contrairement à ce que
certains pensent
que c'est un coup des faits ils ont
appelé la mairie et il souhaite me
rencontrer et la maman d'ailleurs
souhaitent venir dans le bureau dixit
selon ses propos du maire en tirant les
oreilles de son enfant d'accord donc ça
veut dire que ce type de mesure fonction
et je m'en réjouis ils font quoi les
parents dans la vie vous le savez vous
pas les loups sont d'accord je rentre
pas dans la vie privée d'accord c est le
jeune homme une pas de nouvelles idées y
compte passer j'espère qu'il viendra
avec sa maman d'accord voilà très bien
dit on reviendra dans ce cas là bien sûr
sur notre sur une décision alors cette
décision a fait énormément parler que
c'est la première fois que ça arrive
vous avez voulu faire un coup de com où
c'est vraiment une décision qui nous
tient à coeur ce que c'est parce que
vous avez dit je serai le premier à
nancy greene ça m'étonne vous qui êtes
hyper connectés ah oui vous savez quand
même que ça a été le cas par le passé à
béziers
parce qu'on en parle là c'est une somme
à valence ça fait quand même la cena
c'était à moi ça m'est tombé dessus
parce que pour moi c'est du bon sens
veut dire le maire il est chargé des
poules de pouvoir de police mme officiel
politicien il doit donc assurer la
sécurité la trame ténue et l'ordre dans
sa commune
dix mois dans la commune ils étaient
contents de cette décision devait
écouter qu'un jour la réaction mais sont
unanimes de la droite à la gauche
d'accord alors aussi bien dans ma
commune que qu'à l'extérieur alors
regardez ici d'ailleurs sur le plateau
il ya énormément d'eau il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont d'accord avec vous qui
trouve que vous avez pris la bonne
décision je crois que ce n'est pas le
cas de nos intervenants soir benjamin
lucas et patrick mennucci qui ne sont
pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous
benjamin qu'est ce que vous reprochez à
cette décision mais d'abord moi je suis
je pense comme beaucoup de français
fatigué on a eu en septembre la
polémique sur l'usagé de l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire par les familles moder
et qu'on accusait d'acheter des écrans
plats on a depuis des mois des années
dans ce pays un débat qui consiste à
dire que si les chômeurs ne trouvent pas
de travail c'est parce qu'ils sont
fainéants qu'il faut baisser leurs
prestations pour qu'on trouve du travail
vous pouvez maintenant deux saisons ce
qu'a dit le chef de l'état gagne il faut
traverser la rue et c'est maintenant
comme très souvent d'ailleurs une
polémique qui vise à quoi à dire qu'on
va priver toute une famille dead
éventuelle par ailleurs qu'elles n'ont
pas demandé parce que l'un de leurs
gamins a eu une conduite répréhensible
mais ce qu'on va un moment donné dans ce
pays arrêtez de considérer qu'on peut
régler des problèmes de la société en
tapant les plus pauvres au portefeuille
est ce qu'à un moment donné on va
arrêter d'avoir ces espèces de réflexe
de taper toujours sur les plus pauvres
avec sa norma jean macé à temps et je te
dis
oui mais pas dans ce cas pourquoi parler
d'être de
nouveau monde donc ça passe bien que
c'est la communication et je vous dira
pas laver ou plus ou moins sûr puisque
je vais plus voir si vous mais ça n'est
pas le cas de la famille bird venir a
mis dix ans à venir les situations elles
peuvent être complexes de l'efficace
dans une famille les situations elles
peuvent être complexes par exemple
est-ce que ça vous viendrait à l'idée de
retirer à un certain jean-marie sa
pension de retraite parce que la fille
marine a tapé dans la caisse au
parlement européen non donc il faut
aussi la être un mari
déjà
[Applaudissements]
mais toi ici compter de ce jour là
dedans on connaît pas cette famille a
pas d'autres gamins qui relie m'a
demandé des aides de l'anah idéologie
besoin pour s'assurer que vous êtes
sébastien malheureusement et que les
ouvriers vous ont quitté depuis
maintenant quelques années a laissé
mathieu de leur moitié pas d'accord avec
le génial parce que monsieur je suis
désolé vous défendez ma les gens vous
mélangez tout c'est une excellente
décision pourquoi parce qu'un a marre
maintenant qu'on va se porter justement
l'éducation sur les professeurs sur la
police c'est toujours les projets shérif
de larimer de sa commune
de 14 ans aujourd'hui doit les ducs et
doit le punir doit le récompenser ça
c'est le rôle des châssis vous fait des
l'alexa attentifs dans le comportement
de leur poser en franck et délinquants à
14 ans voilà vous le reprenez vous parc
c'est à vous de gérer votre emprunt ce
n'est pas à la cause de monsieur il est
maire il n'est pas gardé attendre donc
y'a un moment je suis pas dieu pardon je
fais un petit tour de tapas que gilbert
s est pas du tout d'accord avec vous
c'est monstrueux ce que vous dites avec
vous monsieur le maire respectueusement
un élu de la république qui pratiquait
du chantage à l'argent c'est pas dit
légal illégal
karine et
sa famille à
toute la ville de moissac à l'or illégal
parce qu'en france on peut pas faire
payer quelqu'un pour la fumée c'est
discriminatoire lee vous allez la jetée
à la rue elle avait besoin de vous
attendue également cette décision il
ya quelques années quand j'étais
adolescente que maintenant vous êtes un
très mauvais chroniqueur pour les
meilleurs chroniqueurs cependant vous
c'est un compliment mais c'est ça et
vous mélangez le les allocations et les
aides sociales aux habitations c'est le
département et l'état c'est lié à la
législation le maire n'a aucun pouvoir
là dessus sa mère étant pas pouvoir
supprimer le rsa ou à la conscience
canadiana partie ch sur les aides
sociales municipales un maire avec son
conseil d'administration d'access a tous
les pouvoirs pour définir un règlement
intérieur c'est l'automne et les maires
règlement des six bottés et je rappelle
ce règlement intérieur a été voté aussi
par les gens de gauche cher monsieur
c'est pour vous dire que donc nous
faisons de la déçu l'unanimité
romantique roma jalons avoir patrick
mennucci qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous pas trop y penser un débris était
passé et je pense qu'il y aille je ne
met pas du tout en cause le fait que mr
puisqu'au moquer des familles je les
fais moi même j'étais maire du
centre-ville de mancey et c'est
d'ailleurs une prérogative dans la loi
c'est existe il ya pas de difficultés je
crois qu'il ya deux problèmes ni un
problème qui est est-ce que c'est utile
je vais y revenir mais ça mais pour vous
c'est utile ou kaka oui je pense que
l'utilité ne peut se construire que dans
la légalité donc je vais dire pourquoi
ce qu'a fait le maire de moissac est
illégal en réalité la légalité doit se
baser sur une décision qui ne peut pas
être discriminatoire et il y a des
exemples où des mères ont mis en place
des systèmes de ce type mais ils les ont
encadrés
on joue je vous j'ai appelé tout à
l'heure ce que j'ai vu qu'il y avait
plusieurs villes effectivement même
qu'il y avait ces choses là j'appelais
karl olive qui est maire de poissy mois
ci que la cia car après qu'il ait fait
son match
il est donc au coeur de l'actu
il paraît que le penalty était vrai il
fait beau le président a en effet menacé
lors du match et donc j'ai appelé karl
olive et humain il m'a expliqué comment
il faisait en réalité pour faire ce qu'a
fait le maire de moissac il faut
encadrer légalement la décision c'est à
dire il faut d'abord une décision du
conseil municipal et il faut que la
décision évident ne porte c'est à dire
une délibération qui soit connu comme on
fait une loi un texte et il faut que la
délibération ne portait évidemment que
sur ce que fait la ville de manson 5la
allocations et je pense c est un peu une
confusion donc par exemple eu et il faut
que cette cette aide soit une aide qui
soit lié à un avantage en matière de
le pouvoir d'achat par exemple à poissy
vous avez 40 euros par enfant pour
prendre des abonnements dans des clubs
vous allez acheter votre licence de foot
de rugby c est donc là la mairie de
poissy a décidé si il y à un individu
est là j'aime bien à la légalité c'est
pas une famille c'est un individu
désigné c'est à dire l'enfant intel
l'amfar intel a fait effectivement a
jeté une pierre sur la police municipale
la ville décide de le sanctionner à
partir d'une décision qui a été validé
par la préfecture
des yvelines
terminé voilà comme je bouge mais c'est
intéressant de savoir qu'on peut le
faire mais qu'il faut l'encadrer paraît
donc à partir du moment où le conseil
municipal a décidé
effectivement les individus et non pas
la famille parce qu'il ya le problème de
la discrimination
vous ne pouvez pas faire porter sur le
frère de cet individu par exemple une
responsabilité qui aurait été fait et
pas
dans une cadre ya des cadres légaux
nicipal it et qui le font il ya des
disques oui mais là le ciel ouvert
défaits à moissac peut être attaqué
devant une tribune au ministre
fait et ça a été c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent que c'est
c'est une bonne et c'est aussi par
exemple fiona oui moi monsieur le maire
vraiment j'ai envie de vous dire merci
même si je suis un peu embêté après je
vous expliquerai pourquoi mais merci
d'avoir montré l'exemple parce que ce
jeune là qu'à 14 ans ils détériorent bd
des monuments défendent et moi demain
alice est là qui appartient à la commune
et pourquoi donner de l'argent à la
famille alors que de son côté le môme
lui il est incapable de se comporter
correctement
les
cff et les amis qui respecte la
constitution
des principes de droit c'est que on est
responsable soi même monsieur
ruiz s'est ouvert n'est pas très
pratique on n'est pas dans la loi
s'il te plaît l'ordre juste que je
trouve malheureux c'est que aujourd'hui
on soit obligé de pénaliser la famille
alors qu'il ya un monde qui va s'en
sortir indemne celle ci parce qu'en fait
c'est la salle sur les songes qu'est ce
qu'il va faire aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir qu on va pouvoir le
punir sans laisser la situation mais
nous on expliqué mais qu'est ce qu'on va
faire monsieur expliquez moi puisque
vous avez l'air de mieux la connaître
que moi c'est qu'on va faire à nouveau
sanctionnées aux gammes cet homme femme
rousse et adolescents pardon sanctionner
la ville de religieux montre que c'est
possible mais pas les honorer la mémoire
la police
nationale jamais
jamais je pense qu'on n'entend pas la
même chose parce qu'ils vous dit que la
famille a dû rappeler dans les heures à
venir s'expliquer baffinland ça ne
m'intéresse pas 9e par alain me dites
pas que la famille est mise de côté et
sans laquelle la famille n'a pas
benjamins
benjamin gérard dans la ville basse à
main qui trouve sa sévère ouais c'est
bien parce que moi ce qui me dérange
avec yvon c'est le côté un peu global en
fait on punit l'ensemble une famille il
ya des frères et soeurs et de ce que
disait et mois d'angoissé mois ce qui
m'angoisse avance c'est que dans ce pays
vu le contexte actuel voilà oui les
manteaux de se faire remarquer de façon
un peu un peu un peu dur on est dans une
phase où soit là c'est ce que ce qui est
à droite mais beaucoup moi ce qui
m'angoisse et que ça va créer un
précédent et que sous prétexte que
quelqu'un a fait ils vont le faire dans
n'importe quel sens ça se fait dans
toutes les familles mais moi et moi ça
me fait peur parce que je trouve ça
effectivement discriminant mais moi j'ai
pas envie qu'on soit dans un état qui
n'est pas constitutionnel parce que
c'est normal mais je les aime et vous tu
sais pas c'est le principe ouais ça
m'énerve et sur sa juste mal mais vous
êtes en train de perdre aux yeux non je
vous emmerde juliette qu'on n'a pas
entendu mais déjà j'aimerais
tellement plaisir de rencontrer un élu
avec as tu vas kiffer de couillet à
rennes on a perdu ça fait baiser est ce
qui te prend juliette
les missiles a compris la veulent les
français il a compris que les français
en avaient ras le casque de payer pour
des gens qui le reste exane a noirci et
c'est pas un phénomène monsieur ce qui
se passe à droite aujourd'hui la france
se droitise parce que les gens en ont
marre ils n'en peuvent plus de voir des
gamins de 14 ans leur cracher à la
gueule et à la gueule de la police donc
je suis ravi je serre la main et je vous
dis moi
c'est bien
et
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
alors deux gamins parce qu'en fait sur
envoyé en maison de redressement sa
maison laurier gueuler vous auriez fait
leur effet coût du risque vous voulez
quoi finalement je me laisse mode attend
dé moi je ne sais pas si c'est un lien
avec les paire de testicules les uns des
autres par contre je crois que d'un état
de droit comme la vôtre et diane quelque
chose qui
s'appelle la justice avec ses principes
son président du coût
prévisible des droits quand vous êtes
attendait stein que les affaires les
stars mondiales souvent elle relève des
choses beaucoup plus complexe juillet le
bien le mal et quand un gamin de 14 ans
pratiquent des actes qui si personne ne
cautionne il faut s'interroger pourquoi
les communes il est ce qu'il ya une
responsabilité de la famille ou pas je
n'en sais rien
ce n'est pas le plat
des lois
il y avait et on les respecte c'est vrai
maire n'a fait qu'elle ait fait un
dictateur low cost yoplait
ne paraît pas du sommet sinon vous allez
casser les yaka watts du maire
monsieur qui barrent de justice on va
rire à nice il ya cinq ans un drame un
jeune garçon mineur a été dérobé une
bijouterie le bijoutier lui a tiré
dessus il est mort ils sont que ce
garçon était 17 fois récidiviste à moins
de 16 ans voilà voilà on en est la
justice donc ce garçon est mort et le
bijoutier
arrivé
effectivement on servir envoyez-vous
effectivement si on avait arrêté des
allocations que si les parents avaient
repris ce gamin vous croyez qu'un maire
omar sheika sauvegarde lac saint jean
est un acte répréhensible c'est que ces
quelques euros d'allocations ou d'être
sûr que
16e bien sûr du talent est à 4 euros il
ya 800 personnes qui manquent tueur bien
sûr que ça joue monsieur le
monde jamal abou dis des bêtises je
pense excusez moi parce que ouais c'est
pas ça ça n'a rien à voir c'est pas
parce qu'on on enlève quelques euros à
la famille que ça va faire bouger les
choses au contraire ce qui va se passer
c'est que les parents vont être plus
répressifs agréable c'est ce que l'on
savait pas si c'était ben c'est sûr mais
regarde on voit bien que la mer à la lan
non mais moi je trouve sa sévère pour la
famille parce que voilà vous l'avez dit
les frères les soeurs sont touchées ça
veut dire un sévère mais mais mais là
pourquoi ils ont fait ça il s'est juste
pour que les parents puissent
intervenir les seniors il y aura une
répression plus importante des parents
c'est ce que disent les limites ceux qui
sont d'accord avec le maire gilles
pargneaux ce n'est pas d'accord moi je
trouve ça un petit peu sévère aussi mais
gilles pourquoi ou preuve n'êtes pas
d'accord break avec ce que quand je me
fais l'avocat du diable comme un seul
homme au rectorat je l'avais envoyé le
showcase à le dire madame juliette la
circonscription vous choque parce que
c'est pas de la répression qu'il faut
c'est de l'éducation
pas de bêtises mais bien sûr qu'ils
aient peur et pas moi qui m'en donner
l'éducation et dont les
cantons le millionnaire langue seconde
arrêter de crier de dire juge
considérait vous allez opter aussi non
mais non répond posément aider les
parents en difficulté
ses parents vous croyez que ça le
jul franchement mais ouais je vais vous
dire la vérité vous êtes heu
c'est pas possible d'être aussi des
magouilles je sais je suis moi c'est ma
mère que je
l'entendis croches en régie rien du tout
monsieur gardasil est d'aller
je suis dans le réel et il ya des
milliers d'élus locaux et des millions
de français qui n'ont pas là votre
vision mais voyez que vous êtes sur des
animaux et les milliers de
familles ont donné sur les
familles qui vivent en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté dans ma commune j'ai 35 % de
jeunes qui vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté dans les deux quartiers nous
sommes là pour les aider faisons un
magasin comme le fait la gauche c'est en
solo que l'on a déjà
séduit que les ouvrières devons nous
aller vous mais je suis là devient
une délibération ce qui va ici d'un de
cadres et mais s'il ya des endroits ya
des règles
qu'en sait on a tout aurait débuté
jamais mordu
laissez moi
vous donner quoi alors pour cet enfant
de quatre buts et
transmise à la préfecture pour une bonne
part de légalité parce vous proposez
moi les mecs là ça se passe comme ça que
la préfecture et franchement je m'en
bats les couilles excusez moi je vous
dis la vérité donc là où les dans un
truc on est dans la brique cc démo était
de l'émotion c'est une décision est ce
qu'ils ont bien fait de la prendre ou
pas après lui il sait ce qu'il va faire
avec la loi il va essayer de la faire
passer ça il va essayer de faire passer
donc c'est passé à côté ça franchement
c'est dans un truc juridique vraiment on
est on est pas là dedans alors les
données des coucous du maire tout à
l'heure
face irresponsable toute une famille des
actes commis
dès mardi jeunes marty khl de la
renommée
du hockey manière on peut rêver
je ne fais pas technique patrick qu'est
que c'est quoi votre solution voila
voila c'est la question de juillet c'est
comme cela la solution c'est une écoute
et cette famille d'accord je sais pas ça
se passe mais que le maire s'occupe de
lemon comme ça c'est légitime d'accord
on va dire à nu mais qui le droit de
s'en occuper contrairement à vous je
passe et aux actions dans la salle je
pense que ce qui est très important
quand on prendre des actes de sanctions
dures et précieux c'est qu'ils soient
encadrés c'est dire que cannes ce n'est
pas un cadre et
les gens qui le maire n'avait pas il ne
serait rien arriver à cela ils
souhaitaient voter
sophie monde en vous alors moi oui parce
qu'en père jean temps j'entends un maire
qui a l'air plutôt d'être dans le
dialogue c'est à dire que voilà il a
convoqué les parents bien que la toile
il a tout
comme la nôtre en
tout cas sur cette affaire là il a
convié les parents les parents ont
refusé de se présenter le maire dit
lui-même que si les parents se
présenteraient pourra revenir sur cette
décision
vous stigmatisez la famille en disant ce
sont les gens les plus pauvres ils n'ont
pas demandé une aide donc je vois pas
quel est le leur
c'est d'abord et
c'est l'essentiel je suis mère de
famille de trois enfants je peux bien
pour vous mathieu que quand les enfants
nous échappent et ça peut arriver aussi
on ne peut pas toujours responsabiliser
les parents c'est à dire que tu as des
gosses mais combien de temps tu vas
parraitre
tu peux les éduquer tu ne peux pas les
enfermer tu ne peux pas les mettre en
prison c'est pas possible dans l'étude
il avait l'habitude d'aller y est je
suis d'accord avec toi en revanche ses
parents doivent répondre activement des
actes il a de leur temps en se pointant
est en essai en trouver merci
à toi mais finalement il en appelle à la
générosité des leçons je sais le jeu ne
pas comporter en méprisant monsieur le
maire et la ville alors j'ai pas un
traître jours le sommaire la dendre me
rendre là on peut pas faire de travail
et l'intérêt général parce qu'il n'y a
pas de dégradation de la république chez
ben crachats talent mais ils vont pas
faire de travail d'intérêt général alors
c'est la justice oui et elle agit
mais
ça allait
l'idée là typiquement la foule dit on
est dans un cas on est dans la rue on
est con et dont on est dans une année
dans une dans une politique archaïque
excusez-moi de mériel jupe aux genoux a
laissé l'abri cinq jours de rappel à la
loi dans une mairie tél 06 21 l'annoncé
publique a
laissé trop longtemps
comme la banane dans
les quartiers nord de marseille
théâtre avec une société on tient tous
les individus d'une famille comme
responsable de spéculateurs et les
sociétés une société où on dit la
justice
[Applaudissements]
je vous le dis
quoique
[Applaudissements]